bonsoir mesdames messieurs c'était jour
de deuil national en algérie et au
burkina faso au lendemain de
l'écrasement d'un avion survenu dans le
désert du mali et la france aussi est en
deuil
sur les 118 victimes de la tragédie 54
sont d'origine française gabrielle
dejazet des milliers de débris comme des
confettis
voilà tout ce qui reste du vol air
algérie a h5 1017 l'appareil a été comme
pulvérisé sur place 180 soldats français
et malien s'activent déjà la zone de 300
mètres sur 300 m environ et sécuriser
les recherches ont commencé mais elle
s'annonce difficile
les experts français du bureau enquête
et accident doivent arriver dès l'aube
demain
la priorité est de retrouver rapidement
les restes des victimes
dans ces circonstances dramatiques tout
doit être fait pour que les dépouilles
des victimes puisse être rendu le plus
rapidement possible à leurs proches cet
homme attend le retour des corps pour
entamer son deuil
il a perdu son frère sa femme et leurs
quatre enfants ainsi qu'un neveu dans
l'écrasement
avec sa femme ils ont fait l'effort pour
amener les uns fera découvrir un peu
leurs racines et ra l'a fait
et c'est fini c'est plus de 20 familles
françaises sont endeuillées l'une
d'entre elles a perdu dix de ses membres
sur ce vol funeste toutes les familles
ont été contactées une à une par les
autorités françaises quatorze autres
nationalités comptent parmi les victimes
ces libanais ne reverront pas leurs
proches qu'ils rentraient fêter la fin
du ramadan
l'algérie et le burkina faso ont décrété
des journées de deuil national
en france le gouvernement réunis en
cellule de crise promet soutien et
transparence il est encore trop tôt pour
tirer les conclusions elles viendront il
y à des hypothèses et notamment
climatiques mais nous n'écartons aucune
parce que nous voulons tout savoir sur
ce qui s'est produit
dès demain le président de la république
recevra ici au ministère des affaires
étrangères les familles et les proches
des victimes
54 d'entre elles étaient françaises
si gabriel dejazet radio-canada paris